for approximately 80 years the notion of
what a man should be like has been
heavily influenced by the idea of cool
the cast of seductively cool figures
includes Humphrey Bogart jean-paul
Belmondo Machado Mastriani James Bond
Bob Dylan Ryan Gosling and Benedict
Cumberbatch the cool man doesn't try too
hard you don't see them floundering
about in a panic but they succeed anyway
they are physically confident they can
scale a mountain or saunter down a
deserted Street in the middle of the
night if they have to kill someone
they'll do it neatly with minimal fuss
they don't worry they're self-contained
and sure of themselves their trousers
are always a perfect fit they express
themselves briefly but their words are
always to the point they're not meek in
the face of authority but they don't
crave power themselves they are
independent the essential characteristic
of the cool man
is an aura of invulnerability well
handled without any showing off or
bragging when the house is on fire the
cool man doesn't scream or call the fire
brigade temperatures rising babe he
quips to his current girlfriend as she
emerges from the shower then he casually
puts out the blaze himself when the
waiter spills cocktail over him the cool
man
doesn't get flustered he removes his
jacket and looks even better in his
shirt when his boss is being difficult
the cool man smiles ironically he can
walk away from the job at any moment
this is what as a man one is supposed to
be like for decades some of the most
astute and creative minds have devoted
themselves to making this notion of
masculinity attractive it's been
portrayed as enviable seductive to women
and well-dressed and the image has
worked it's what you need to be to be a
real man and perhaps daily this model of
manhood tortures us with the gap between
its ideals and our reality but there's
another more realistic and more
important vision of what a good man is
like that's comparatively been given
very much less attention and creative
encouragement this is the very opposite
of the cool man what we call the
man the warm man doesn't put out many
fires by himself he hasn't killed anyone
either he is instead very much alive to
his own anxiety he would drop the gun
and would tell you he did quite candidly
what's distinctive and admirable is the
warm man's relationship to this anxiety
he's aware of it honest about it funny
with it and yet not overwhelmed by it
the warm man has a good sense of her
demented and fragile we all are so he
goes out of his way to reassure to be
forgiving and to be gentle he's tried
very hard at times to get things to work
out better for himself but frequently it
just hasn't worked the warm man has
known many sorrows he has done stupid
things
he has lost people he loved he has made
daft decisions his weaknesses have made
him immensely generous to others when
the waiter spills the cocktail the warm
hero laughs they've spilt a few
cocktails themselves and leaves a
generous tip if he can when he forgets
someone's name which he does quite often
the warm hero is ashamed but frank and
says sincerely I'm really sorry I'm very
embarrassed I know but it's just slipped
my mind forgive me help me out when
they've messed up at work to warm person
admits it Phil sorry
openly apologizes and explains as best
he can what actually went wrong and how
he might put it right in the future the
essence of the warm man is vulnerability
well handled he is conscious of his
flaws and failings but uses this
knowledge to become interestingly
humorous and a rich source of sympathy
for the secret troubles of every life he
encounters ideally one day it will be as
desirable to be called warm as it
currently is to be labeled cool
there will be lists of the 40 warmest
men under 40 boys will come home from
school and complain to their mothers I
can't do it I can't I don't know how to
be warm girls at fashionable bars will
take mental notes of whether warm guys
are sitting and in the secret soul of
every man there will be a quiet steady
yearning to be as warm as they possibly
can we love bringing you these films if
you want to help us to keep bringing you
thoughtful content please consider
supporting us by visiting our shop at
the link on your screen now